well first of all I want to say that
it's such a pleasure to visit again with
the numberphile family I haven't seen
you guys in a long time
so hope you're doing well I wanted to
talk to you about something which I've
been thinking about lately and part of
the reason is that I'm teaching this
class at UC Berkeley linear algebra it
has to do with numbers because of course
you know I love numbers
I do numbers for a living I'm a
mathematician hello and I know you guys
also like numbers because you know we
are watching numberphile but also being
a mathematician I think I have a certain
vantage point which sort of enables me
to see perhaps better than people who
are not professional mathematicians not
only the the uses of numbers but also
limitations of numbers and this in
particular you know I was interested in
this as I was following a debate a
recent debate which many of you may have
seen in a play out in the media about
artificial intelligence what do we mean
by artificial intelligence course we can
be in many different things but
essentially we talk we talk about
computers right we talk about computers
we are talking about computer programs
we talk about algorithms how do they
work they work with numbers to me when
people say that humans are just
specialized computers and eventually
we'll just be build more and more
powerful computers so that eventually
they will surpass the power of human
that kind of line of reasoning to me
cannot be traced this idea that somehow
human is nothing but a machine the human
is nothing but a sequence of numbers it
is really something which work lives and
dies by numbers you see so that's why
I'm not suggesting at all that there is
nothing to math the numbers of course
there are many other things right so for
example there's geometry and so on and
in fact I will demonstrate now or I will
I hope I will demonstrate and that
that's my purpose that in mathematics
there are many things which we often
confuse with numbers but which are not
actually numbers or they could be
represented by numbers but numbers do
not read into justice to them and so I
would like to show you this one example
which came up in my linear algebra class
and this has to do with vectors so look
at this bra
paper so it is on this on this on this
table right imagine that it extends to
infinity in all directions so you can
think of it as a 2-dimensional vector
space let me be a little bit more
concrete let me pick a point there we go
so this point will be the origin this
will be sort of like the zero point of
this vector space okay and now I want to
talk about vectors and so a vector to me
would be something like this you see
it's an interval which has a length and
a direction and it starts at this origin
which I have fixed once and for all this
is fixed once and for all
here is another example of a vector and
so on so a vector is like here so the
totality of all vectors is essentially
the totality of all the points of this
brown-paper right because for every
point I can just connect that point to
the origin and point to that point now
it's not just a static thing it's not
just a collection of vectors which it is
but there is more for example we can add
any two vectors to each other and many
of you may know how to do this it's it's
called a parallelogram rule so that's
the intersection point okay very nice
but it's not very functional because
they are yes the vectors are here they
are concrete they kind of concrete they
live here they have this acceleration
but it's very difficult to work with
them so we try to make it more
functional and we do it more functional
by introducing a coordinate system what
we call a coordinate system or a lineage
will report introducing a basis so now
we come to the crucial point okay and
the crucial point is the basis I want to
introduce a coordinate grid here that's
what I want to do I don't coordinate
grid and so for example I can use that
well let me use in this color so I will
have two coordinate axis one of them
let's say goes like will go like this my
drawing is not particular perfect you
know I have taught two classes today so
please excuse my my wiggly lines but I
hope the point is clear so usually what
we do we say this is x axis and this is
a y axis we know this from school and we
know this even before we study vectors
right we think about it rather usually
as representing points but now I want to
think about Morse vectors and then we
will see why another way to think about
this to give this to access is the same
as to give two unit vectors along this
axis so one of them would be this one
say and let's you know I don't want to
overload it with notation but this could
be one or something and then this would
be another basis vector so this is a
basis their unit so the kind of unit
relative to something but we'll discuss
this what does mean to be unit here's
what I can do I can represent now this
vector by a pair of numbers by simply
taking the projection onto the x axis
and the y axis you see so this point
would be some multiple of this vector so
it would be the corresponding distance
here so it looks like three halves right
so this looks more like this looks sort
of like three halves close to the
holly's if this is one and you have the
little increment which looks like kind
of close to one and this one looks like
let's make it let me make it longer soon
indeed two so it's kind of like just
kind of rounded up okay so then what I
say is that this v1 can be represented
by we usually we write it as a colon as
a call of numbers so the first we write
the first coordinate three curves and
then we write this two so that's what we
do in linear as well but other people
sometimes people write also like this
it's you it's your choice rather
floating on the paper now it kind of
almost has value that's right it becomes
a very concrete thing it becomes a pair
of numbers okay and it's very very
efficient because once you have once you
have that so every vector can be written
in this form you see my v2 can also be
written as a pair of numbers my v1 plus
v2 committee a pair of numbers and then
we can work with them because for
instance what we are interested often is
some kind of transformation of this
plane and we can feed these vectors this
you know this vector representations
this pairs of numbers into those
transformations so this is all great and
it's very important to do that to kind
of actualize vectors by numbers so they
become actualized you can think also of
this by the way as a kind of a
coordinate grid so I impose a coordinate
grid so then each of them is gets an
address what this is really isn't is the
address of this vector with respect to
this particular coordinate grid it's
very important to realize that the
vector exists even before we introduce a
code
greed and think about it like you said
the ship exists even before we look at
it relative to an island or another ship
or so and so on or you know I exist even
before I have an address before you find
out what my home address is or before I
choose my home you know I already exist
and likewise a vector exists even before
we introduce the coordinate grid and
it's clear why because look I drew it
before I had any coordinate system I
drew it it already it was already there
on a brown paper there is no denying the
fact that it existed before right but
what I did now I impose something on it
the vector if you think about it the
vector couldn't care less what we're
doing vector is just sitting there and
enjoying its life or whatever or
whatever it is whatever it involves you
know but we came yeah I came I imposed
on on this space I imposed by putting
this coordinate system this coordinate
grid and with respect to this coordinate
grid I have now represented that vector
by a pair of numbers but very important
a very important thing to realize at
this point is that I had a choice I had
a choice I could choose this coordinate
grid in a different way and this is what
I teach my students in linear algebra I
tell them someone else could come and
construct a different coordinate system
you see a different coordinates is or I
could change my mind and I could create
a different coordinate system this this
are imagine that decided to base basis
vectors now going along the x and y as I
drew them originally but now imagine
that it there it could be like this or
they could be like this like that and in
principle you don't you don't even have
to be perpendicular to each other as
long as they're not parallel it is my
free will if you wish you know it's my
free will is in choosing that but once
you realize that there are many
coordinate systems many coordinate
systems and I have a choice of making
creating this cornices when someone else
could come you could do it Brady you
could make your own coordinate system
and we cannot I cannot convince you that
my constants better than yours
they all are on equal footing but now
because we now realize that this
involves certain choice names the choice
of the coordinate system it becomes very
very clear that this pair of numbers is
not the same as a vector and and this is
fine this is how it works
but it's very important to realize that
because oftentimes we hear we get so
caught up in this process and we get so
excited that gee we can represent a
vector by a pair of numbers and we
forget the difference and we start it we
convince ourselves we start believing we
start believing that actually there is
no difference between them but what I'm
marking is that there is a big
difference and that's what I teach my
students and this is very important
because you see I mean let me put this
way if I could ask this vector if this
vector could talk and I could ask this
vector
what are you coordinates you know the
record will like worked what are you
talking about what coordinates he
doesn't he or she you know doesn't know
what the coordinates are the vector is
just there it just is
I came and I try to sort of put it in a
box if you will I try to assign some
numbers to it professor you're talking
like a vector is a real thing that we
applied an abstraction onto but isn't
the vector itself an abstraction to
start with a vector is not a real thing
a vector is just as imagined as the
coordinate system that you imposed on
yes and no because well you see they are
abstractions we are now in the world of
abstraction and my point is precisely
even in the abstract world of
mathematics you have entities you have
things like vectors which are not the
same as numbers how can if you
appreciate this how can you believe that
the human being is a sequence of numbers
you see lamian how can you believe that
life is an algorithm if you already see
in mathematics in the abstract world of
mathematics you find things which which
exist which makes perfect what make
perfect sense we can work with them like
take the sum of two vectors without any
reference to coordinates or anything
like this how can you believe that that
is the same as the params it's not if
you look closely at how we got that pair
of numbers out of a vector you realize
that it involved additional choice so
every time we make this procedure we are
projecting that vector sort of onto our
particular frame of reference let's look
at this cup now I can project it onto
the plane okay I can project it onto the
plane when I project it onto the plane I
see what do I see I will
disk well with some little thing
protruding which you know obviously but
more or less the disk and on the other
hand I could project it onto this
whiteboard onto the small what will I
see well if I put it in a particular way
you will just see a rectangle okay so
let's say you look at this projection
what do you see you see a disc and and
all you look here and you see a
rectangle so you might say what is this
is this a disc no is this a
parallelogram again no then someone else
could come and say AHA maybe it is both
a disc and a parallelogram and he or she
would still be wrong because this is an
entirely different thing you see yes I
can project it down and I can record the
information and it may be some useful
information but it doesn't do justice to
this whole thing I neither does any
other projection and likewise with the
vector think of a vector as a cup it's
an object of an entirely different
nature then a pair of numbers you can
apply the same technique not only to
vectors but to other things related to
this vector space for example what we
call linear transformations a typical
example of a linear transformation would
be rotation of this brown paper around
this special point about the central
point and then you know I'm teaching my
class this is a kind of funny thing so
I'm teaching my class this is textbook
which we use and so and I and I get into
this I get to this point the matrix
representation of a linear
transformation they kind of hit me you
know the matrix you know and so of
course you know I remember the famous
movie in this like you know remember the
Morpheus saying to neo do you want to
know what it is and that's exactly what
I'm asking right now do you want to know
what it is well the matrix on the one
hand is a very efficient way to package
information to convert objects like
vectors and linear transformations into
collections of numbers the menu is not
the same as a meal you know you can read
the menu you can go to restaurant it can
read the menu all you want you can even
call the waiter to come to your table
and explain
every ingredient you can ask the chef to
come and explain the process of cooking
you can get all this information but I'm
sorry it's not the same as eating that
meal is eating that dish right so it is
something like this and my point is that
this matrix representation on the one
hand can be very useful just like our
computers are very useful algorithms are
very useful or they can you know if we
forget where they come from where these
programs come from where these numbers
come from and when we forget the
difference between the actual things
they represent and the representation
that's when we create the kind of matrix
that Morpheus was talking about you know
and more if you said you create you know
the prison for your mind that's what we
do when we forget that difference
between the object themselves and the
representations so my point is let's use
that representation let's use those
numbers us use computers you know to our
advantage and we are using them but
let's not forget the difference between
the essence of life so to speak about
things which just are which we are
trying to represent and the sequences of
numbers which we get as the result of
that process of representation
I get asked about this all the time you
know a famous author recently asked me
you know he said so you're a
mathematician would you say that life
was an algorithm you know people ask me
or is a human just a sequence of zeros
and ones you know you have people like
Ray Kurzweil who believe that they will
be able to build machines so that they
could upload their mind the brain or
whatever wherever they got you know onto
those machines